[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission à ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux du sport local
aujourd'hui il y aura comme toujours des
analyses des débats et des duels en
diable et ce quatre chroniqueurs sont
autour de cette table pour m'accompagner
présentation de la a dream team on
commence à ma droite elle nous vient
tout droit de versailles à l'associent à
la fois la volupté de l'esprit à
l'énergie sportive à les spécialistes de
pole dance
on est toujours heureux de la voir sur
ce bateau notre ambassadrice de charme
eden de la grange est avec nous bonjour
que cela est beau mais oui voilà comment
allez vous la petite touche féminine est
bien très bien très bien je reviens
d'une petite semaine de vacances chez au
taquet c'est parfait en pleine forme
très bien on passe de l'autre côté
musique il fête aujourd'hui son
cinquième passage dans cette émission
une manita qu'il espère fêter dignement
c'est un expert handball basket et
football stéphane de bizet sera avec
nous pendant une heure sur ce talk
parfait quand avez-vous stéphane très
bien on s'est qualifié pour la finale de
rugby fauteuil ce que vous faites
également du rugby fauteuil nuits saint
georges
ce fut dure fatigante beaucoup de bobos
il est au final une qualif alors c'était
pas forcément plus reposant que les
vacances de lna si je comprends bien
non non non c'est un autre risque de
vacance pour vraiment des vacances à
l'hôpital s'en rappellent encore en face
de l'autre côté à musique qui nous vient
lui aussi de verser sa spécialité le
rugby il aime batailler dans la mêlée il
n'hésite pas à mettre quelques petit
taquet quand il le faut on le surnomme
le peuple jadida terre dans cette
émission pierre chevallier du rugby-club
de versailles est avec nous également
formé bonheur à tous salut les copains
le petit taquet dans la mêlée des
petites et grosses foires mais il est
vrai aussi pour les grosses foires il
pas de demi-mesure quand il faut relever
le débat on peut aussi relever une mêlée
tranquille généralement j'ai pas j'ai
pas trop les bras pour le faire mais je
compte sur mes copains pour surcharger
on termine de l'autre côté mesdames et
messieurs je demande le silence une
légende de cette émission est avec nous
aujourd'hui il est là depuis plusieurs
années c'est un un pilier havok
indéboulonnable vous allez passer un bon
moment avec lui à j'en suis sûr j'en lis
ex entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
bonjour à tous bonjour rigal vous êtes
un rock vous et le collège jules mais
bon t'as sur la violence est une
faiblesse de l'esprit pour le best-of
je voulais avant de passer au programme
d'émission commence par un mot de golf
is avait éliminé la ryder cup 2018 au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'anglais
tommy fleetwood et l'italien francesco
molinari avait remporté tous leurs
matches en duo un 4 sur 4 légendaire une
véritable histoire d'amour sportive est
alors née pendant cette compétition les
équipes de la ryder cup europe ont
profité de la saint valentin pour
ressortir une ancienne vidéo
humoristique du duo baptisé à bollywood
regardez
oh
ça fait 1 5 sur 5
car francesco molinari et gagner tous
ses matchs dont son duel avec fila
mikkelson fleet foot avait lui perdu
contre eux de tony finaux voilà pour la
petite précision
qu'en pensez vous autour de cette table
stéphane c'est sympathique
c'est sympathique vous avez dit qu'en
plus de faire des petites vidéos comme
ça c'est à la mode
ils réussissent tout ce qui touche donc
voici c'est bien ça casse un petit peu
peut-être du golfe oui pourquoi pas
c'est c'est notre façon de faire parler
d'eux ils élargissent apple leur talent
j'enregistre dans ces superbes j'adore
ça voilà surtout à le milieu vous l'avez
dit milieu du golf qui est un petit peu
on pas sérieux mais qui reste un petit
peu à la vue de ddd des spectateurs et
téléspectateurs très très snob snobinard
balassa mais jamais un coup de pelle
c'est super bon j'adore ça j'adore
l'humour
hélène êtes fan justement oui ça casse
un petit peu c'est qu'au delà et puis
c'est drôle c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude d'avoir beaucoup d'humour cc
c'est très suivie d'une façon assez
sérieuse et là ça casse un peu ça mange
et bien un grand verre également aussi
pourvu avec des petites raquettes ou à
l'envers c'est tout ce dont le golf
international et français puisque
c'était au national en 2018 a besoin
c'est exactement dans l'esprit déjà
c'est dans un esprit de performance
parce que c'est une des paires les plus
performantes que la team europe de ryder
cup est connue avec 4 sur 4 à 2 et
de toute son histoire je le rappelle
vous le précisez le 5 sur 5 de molinari
et ça effectivement ça casse un petit
peu le mythe et ça ça positionne le
gueule sur sur un côté un petit peu plus
fun un petit peu plus ouvert qui se
prend pas au sérieux c'est une vidéo qui
a été tournée une petite semaine après
la ryder cup 2 septembre 2018 au golf
national qu'il re classe là aussi qu'ils
ressortent un petit peu des cartons ça
fait parler ça fait parler du gol ça le
positionne vraiment sur un terrain où on
attendait pas du tout ces deux champions
là sont absolument remarquable
humainement et golfique mans en termes
de performances sportives
donc c'est vraiment tout ce dont on a
besoin pour promouvoir le golf comme un
sport fun et pas que pantalon à carreaux
et naphtaline et ça marche bien
également sur les réseaux sociaux
complet complet ils ont ils ont
énormément fans l'un et l'autre tommy
fleetwood est un est un joueur en plus
d'être un joueur un joueur
enthousiasmant et d'un joueur fantasque
et qui a aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de
followers ou encore une fois qui se
prend pas au sérieux
francesco molinari lui se prend ne se
prend pas aussi les plus timides
il est plus timide plus réservés donc il
ay la mort il a mûri la mort la
possibilité de
de se lâcher et la juste ensemble
à deux ils ont réussi à ils ont réussi à
lâcher les chevaux et à rendre le golf
un petit peu sexy ouais non sans trouver
les deux titres sont bien trouvés pour
une première participation
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de football américain des
templiers d'elancourt nous ferons
également un coup de projecteur sur
evans spenlé la future pépite des
circuits automobiles mais avant de
développer c'est elle on va parler un
football on commence donc par du
football montigny le bretonneux à
maurepas c'était l'une des affiches ca
quart de finale de coupe des yvelines
dès l'entâme du match maurepas qui
évolue en d1 de district assume son
statut de favori sa division d'écart les
morts parisien se procurent les
meilleures occasions et arrive à marquer
deux fois 2 0 ce sera le score à la
pause en deuxième période
yacoub belfodil s'offre un triplé grâce
à deux nouveaux buts 4 à 0 ce sera le
score final en écoute les réactions
ces frais seront donc fait éliminer
on se fait éliminer salma non bref pas
grand chose à dire nous à part que match
de coupe on aurait dit elle était un peu
accru de la femme étant rentré dans l
envie qu'on a maîtrisé on savait que on
savait qu'on avait les qualités de
défense est fait aux français pour
pouvoir faire la différence si j'ai une
division en dessous donc on savait qu'on
partait avec un petit avantage
après voilà maintenant on a su on a su
montrer les cartes qui avait entre nous
mais c'était bien yacoub belfodil
le prochain tour de la coupe des
yvelines est programmée le dimanche 5
avril que pensez vous de cette victoire
genre 15-0 magnifique du tort
ça s'appelle gic sans appel logique non
pas logique parce qu'on sait jamais
visionné y avait une petite division
d'écart en division i came la coupe de
france est le témoin de ce genre de
rencontre où justement ça permet de
montrer que
le football c'est pas une question de
division puisque tous les ans il ya
toujours des petits poucet qu'ont en
commun dit qu'il irait se glisser dans
les phases de finale donc c'est pas une
preuve
parce qu'ils avaient une division
d'écart c'était une preuve de réussite
et de victoire mais là bon 4 0 là ces
scores sans appel il n'y a pas de souci
bravo aussi pour l'autre équipe de
travailler plus c'était montigny en face
à montigny son huitième de d2 de
district et maurepas et premier de d1
c'est une division du iv du coup il ya
quand même un écart il ya quand même un
écart énorme donc c'est vrai qu'ils sont
voilà ils ont travaillé et ils sont d'un
niveau supérieur
certes mais il y aurait pu y avoir moins
d'écart on aurait pu être surpris par
peut-être un score moins tu le
rencontres tout est possible stéphane
oui enfin moi je pense que la logique a
été respectée ils sont leaders de leur
championnat ils sont
montigny huitième dans sa catégorie je
pense qu'il ya plus de détails ça a été
fait vite fait bien fait réglé c'est
contrairement à l'autre match lot demi
finales ou trappe s'est débarrassé du du
tenant du titre
il ya eu beaucoup animalière et daisy
pardon quan manière qui a battu vélizy
tenant du titre là oui c'est une vraie
surprise
mais pour mort pas c'est logique on est
pas d'accord avec jean lycéens pour une
fois non c'est vrai quand on coupe genre
en général il ya des surprises mais là
ils ont la hiérarchie pardon a été
respectée est-ce qu il ya une petite
déception par rapport à mon ti cats 0
c'est comme un score lourd si on doit
peut-être pu faire mieux que d'être fier
ça semble être ça semble être un fait
deux faits de match ils sont pas rentrés
dedans
d'après ce que disent ce que disent les
différents joueurs interviews et et sur
ce qu'on voit sur les images
ils sont a priori pas rentrer dedans moi
ce que je retiens aussi c'est la manière
la manière dont on ne mord pas maîtrisée
elle ce match avec un petit 1 petit but
signature de belfodil sur le petit
ballon piqué sur le sur son 3ème 2ème ou
3ème but
il ya clairement de la sérénité sur ce
match-là côté mort pas si je sais pas si
c'est logique sportive ou si c'est ici
un match de coupe en tout cas il y avait
il y avait une maîtrise et maîtrise
globale de maurepas qui qui a pas fait
de détail et en l'occurrence younes sur
des matches de coupe comme ça où
ou parfois c'est très accroché elle a
vraiment aucun état d'âme
ils ont assumé leur statut leur
différence de division discussions
considère que l'une est en bas de
deuxième division district et l'autre en
haut de la première il ya presque 2
millions d'écart
donc là là effectivement on sait c'est
somme toute logique
et ils ont fait ils ont fait ça avec
éclat on va revenir sur la victoire de
maurepas est-ce qu'il faut mettre en
avant la prestation d'un joueur comme
yacoub belfodil qui est je le précise le
frère de ishak belfodil qui a joué
notamment aline termine en petite
précision il a marqué 3 buts 1 sur cette
rentrée c'est un attaquant il a fait le
job
il a fait le job d'un attaquant et je
dirais qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que
même si le le ballon piqué qui assure
l'un de ses trois buts je sais plus
lequel le deuxième le deuxième il
le mais il se le fait tout y est le pen
tout seul derrière il ya sûrement deux
autres passes décisives est l'équipe qui
joue dans le sens de l' attaque pour ne
pas faire de détail et pour gagner 4 0
après c'est vrai qu'il faut les mettre
les trois buts mais les plantes ldc sont
tous genres est-ce qu'il faut tout
simplement dire que l'équipe a gagné
grâce à son attaquant ou c'est une
victoire collective
suivi tour collective ce sport collectif
et la pierre là la bienne lyss et une
voile deux lots et un jeu c'est le
résultat
typique et sang froid c'est le résultat
d'un travail collectif mais c'est son
boulot
certains mais il faut les mettre il faut
quand même les mettre au fond
il faut les mettre au fond et à moins
d'avoir un salaire attaquants il ya beau
y avoir un super attaquant si derrière
ça suit pas ça suit pas alors on a pu le
voir sur ces images et joueurs ont fêté
leur but comme si c'était un match de
coupe de france on écoute les réactions
des joueurs sur cette coupe davis et le
département invite tous les comme envie
de la gagne et envie d'aller au bout et
normale comme tout coupe en fait c'est
un match couperet c'est par un
championnat après une saison un match on
gagne c'est comme ça franchement
si c'est cul du cul du plus que du plus
et ça remplit le ce a rempli la salle
des trophées comme on dit une petite
coupe en plus donc voila quoi ça fait
plaisir
la question sur ce thème comprenez vous
cet engouement pour cette coupe des
yvelines vous votez oui ou non
oui pas de débattre monde est d'accord
jean vous a été le premier à dégainer
comme toujours pas toujours mais oui
mais pourquoi parce que ils sont engagés
dans cette compétition et quelques
compétitions que ce soit le but c'est
d'arriver au bout et de décrocher le
titre
donc forcément on ne peut qu'être
favorable et pose idée d'y répondre nos
positions il ya pas à tortiller stéphane
vous êtes d'accord avec jean toujours
tout à l'heure tu as passé d'accord oui
je sais je vais payer après ça là ça
c'est pas grave non oui c'est pour
l'occasion pour les clubs heavy
yvelinois par nom de se mesurer aux
autres clubs de la région d'un niveau
supérieur
c'est toujours un plus pour leur
championnat alors je rappelle à la coupe
des yvelines c'est une compétition de
district c'est à dire que les équipes
vont de la d1 à la des cinq des six de
district ça dépend des districts
forcément du coup on ne retrouve pas des
équipes comme trappe par exemple qui se
retrouvent en r 2 cette année et ce
c'est un championnat et une coupe
concentrer sur la d1a les dessins qui
fait mais c'est un championnat donc on
regarde pas s'ils sont engagés dans ce
championnat
et comme tout championnat que ce soit du
plu au plus bas le but c'est d'arriver
au bout et de décrocher le titre
donc forcément il ya là un moment je
sais si c'est ce qu'il dit des loutres
football par rapport à tout sport
collectif c'est gros chacun son niveau
ils ont la chance ces équipes de foot de
jouer un championnat et de jouer une
coupe voire plusieurs
et là en l'occurrence je compare par
rapport au rugby par exemple on ne joue
on joue qu'un lièvre on court qu'un
livre à la fois qui est le championnat
et éventuellement des qualifications
pour championnat transmet là ils ont ils
ont ils ont de la compétition tout le
temps ils ont de quoi s'étalonner tout
le temps avec les équipes de la poule en
championnat et les équipes classées une
meilleure dans des dans des divisions
supérieures ou inférieures en coupe
qu'elle soit départementale qu'elle soit
nationale ou de la coupe de france ça
donne une autre compétition à gagner et
donc ça donne
comme disait le voeu que me disais
belfodil ccc en gros c'est ça fait une
coupe de plus éventuellement sur
l'étagère mais c'est surtout pendant la
saison ça anime le tout ça va et ça
anime la compétition est-ce que c'est
pas un lot de consolation en quelque
sorte en sachant que la coupe de france
généralement il ya un ou deux clubs
évinois qui arrive loin dans la
compétition
ben non c'est autre chose et s'est
adapté au niveau des équipes de district
tourner vers les régions
mais ça m'a permis quand même deux de
jouer plusieurs compétitions sur une
saison c'est ça a pas pris ça pour une
pour une équipe de sport de sportifs et
pour des compétiteurs
est ce que vous comprenez également
hélène l'engouement qu'il ya dans les
tribunes on l'a vu sur les images
précédentes
il ya énormément de monde à chaque fois
dans les tribunes voilà pour la coupe
des îles alors qu'en championnat ce
n'est pas forcément le cas non mais je
pense que justement les gens se sont
plus proches des des tournois des
championnats comme ça c'est c'est
beaucoup plus local et c'est on voit les
images mais c'est génial en rose il se
voit là c'est génial pour des équipes
d'être temps suivi
dix huit finales entre guyancourt et
mord pas pour une qualification en
finale bien côté plus familial aussi
plus local pour le développement du
sport des différents niveaux cccd
championnat différence de la coupe de
france par exemple il ya peu d'élus là
c'est vraiment proche de chez eux
c'est proche de chez chacun des
supporters il ya généralement pas de
panneau gros transport et agro trajet à
faire donc donc cesser c'est une
compétition domestique locales et qui
plaît parce que c'est juste c'est juste
à côté et est vraisemblablement on
connaît même les joueurs qui sont dans
les équipes voire dans les deux équipes
donc c'est dans la ccc enthousiasmant et
le fait que ce soit un match à
élimination directe forcément ça rajoute
stéphane s'amuse comme ça ça fait de
l'enjeu
et puis au final avec le meilleur club
des yvelines c1 c'est un petit quelque
chose en plus c'est prestigieux ses
prestigieux voilà on a gagné la coupe
des yvelines voilà c'est tout on prend
bon c'est toujours moins prend au
prochain tour de la coupe des yvelines
le 5 avril prochain on va voir le tirage
au sort a été effectué on va voir les
affiches qui vont apparaître à l'écran
coignières excusez moi c'était les
quarts de finale alors coignières va
recevoir maurepas pour le prochain tour
on va voir bailly noisy hardricourt
coignières et maurepas se sont qualifiés
et konya recevra more more pas le 5
avril prochain et bay noisy recevra à
indret cours on continue par du football
américain les templiers d'elancourt en
mode c'est pas gagné c'est pas gagné
pour mort par gagner pour moi pas non là
coignard gagne de sortir le tenant
c'est un coignières ça va ça va être
chaud je pense que ça va être chaud mais
incognito vocal hier non jeudi à
maurepas ne me reconnais là ça va cogner
alors continue par le football américain
les templiers d'elancourt en mode
rouleau compresseur les élans courtois
n'ont pas fait de détail ce samedi 22
février à domicile contre l'aide au
coeur de nantes
les élans courtois l'emportent sur le
score de 51 des voix après avoir dominé
l ensemble de la partie réaction c'est
une belle victoire
on a on a été plein partout autant en
défense qu'en attaque
franchement ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir de le voir que mes coéquipiers
prennent du plaisir et du coup voilà on
a on a montré ce qu'on avait à montrer
maintenant certes on a fait beaucoup de
fautes mais on va apprendre de nos
erreurs et essayer de faire mieux au
classement les templiers d'elancourt se
replace cette troisième victoire en
quatre matches leur permet d'occuper la
deuxième place de leur poule derrière
les léopards de rouen les play-offs de
fin de saison sont donc accessibles
ainsi qu'une montée en première division
c'est un objectif maintenant on en est
encore loin là c'est plutôt en phase de
playoffs on pourra avoir une vraie
indication sur sûr sur cette question
mais ça reste un de nos objectifs
maintenant c'est une marche qui est très
très hot
on a encore beaucoup de beaucoup de
travail et pas mal de matches mais on va
on va pousser en fait au plus loin pour
atteindre cet objectif
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le 1er mars prochain sur le
terrain des diables rouges de villepinte
la question sur ce thème at on été trop
dur avec les templiers d'elancourt non
pour pierre chevalier le vert étant oui
on est trop dur où elle était trop dur
oui on a été trop dur
[Musique]
non moi je vais dire alors non non non
alors pourquoi vous êtes indécis
je pense que c'est aussi une façon de
de faire que ça se bouge aussi un peu
ils vont ils ont compris qu'ils étaient
vraiment vraiment la très en retard et
au bout du bout du classement
maintenant voilà il remonte c'est très
bien mais non je pense que c'était toute
façon c'était complètement justifiée par
rapport à leur attitude à leur jeu à
l'équipe
voilà près ils ont montré qu'ils étaient
capables de remporter des matchs
maintenant on va voir ce que ça donne au
prochain match et on espère que ça va
pas repartir à linverse excès oui parce
que ça bouge beaucoup chez une belle
réaction d'orgueil de la réaction
d'orgueil pourquoi ils ont distribué de
la titane or et inova bah voilà c'est
tout oui je pense qu'ils se sont sentis
blessés et ils ont bien réagi par ce
propos par mes propos alors je rappelle
qu'ils avaient perdu leur premier match
de la saison contre les léopards de
rouen 22 à 9 et on habite et où est du
coup très critique 1 / juste après cette
défaite sur le résultat mais sur leur
latitude sur wallop mais c'est vrai il
était chaud chaud et ça sur l'attitude
gens c'est sur l'attitude mais c'est à
dire que là je pense qu'ils ont il ya
quelques quelques quelquefois des
défaites qui sont constructives et qui
ressemble pas des victoires mais presque
qui servent énormément
et là ça a été leur cas je crois que là
on entend on entend le commentaire de du
des responsables ont reçu la défense
il ya beaucoup de lucidité beaucoup
d'humilité chose qui n'avait peut-être
pas un début d'un début de saison donc
je crois que cette défaite là bas ça
leur a permis de vraiment redescendre
les pieds bien sur terre
et puis arrêtez de croire qu'ils étaient
peut-être largement dessus de tout le
monde
ils ont certainement retravailler avec
peut-être beaucoup moins de prétention
beaucoup plus d'humilité et les
résultats sont là et là quand on voit
que il est plus modérée dans ses paroles
si on ressortait les interviews de début
de saison c'était beaucoup
et la saison d'avant n'en parlons pas là
on sent on sent une modération sens de
l'humilité
on sent de la lucidité dans son discours
par rapport aux performances sportives
et là ils sont rentrés dans une une
belle spirale positive et c'est tout ce
qu'on leur souhaite
est ce que les changements dans l'équipe
non le punk changerait donc c'est
vraiment leur travail et l'arrêt le fait
qu'ils aient réalisé 2 je crois que
c'est peut-être nous accorder beaucoup
de crédit ou beaucoup trop de crédit sur
le plateau de cette émission aussi aussi
spécialiste sommes nous mais pour ma
part entre guillemets en notamment au
football américain j'y connais pas grand
chose est ce qu'ils regardent bon rythme
avec le réclusion temps peut-être est-ce
qu'il veut rien plaisir à faire cette
émission est ce que la repasse en
causerie d'avant match et en
entraînement disons vous voyez ce que ce
que les uns et les autres dit sur nous
je ne pense pas je vois les faits des
informations en tout cas avoir grillé le
8a photo bientôt dix ans pour aller pour
les maîtres des déplacements par les
gens là bien résumé c'est avant tout au
delà du sportif c'est une question
d'état d'esprit
si jamais on a pu lors de l'aiguillon et
les aiguillonner un petit peu parce
qu'ils ont vu un replay de l'émission en
disant qu'ils avaient manqué d'humilité
tant mieux qui vous dit que 7,7 ses
propos qu'on a pu tenir sur leur état
d'esprit plus que sur leurs compétences
ne leur accordent n'aura pas servi pour
revoir un petit peu le discours équipe
qui sait peut-être changer un petit peu
la méthode d'entraînement et la
préparation mentale
en tout cas 100% d'accord avec jean le
ski resort maintenant en termes de
communication sportive est donc positive
est beaucoup plus dans les plaques
beaucoup plus humble beaucoup plus
lucide beaucoup plus beaucoup plus en
adéquation avec les objectifs
pour l'instant il avance masqué et ils
redeviennent peut-être outsider pour la
montée en 1re div là pour l'instant du
faux ils sont premiers de leur poule à
égalité avec les léopards d'oran mais vu
que les léopards les ont battus lors du
premier match sont devant et on leur a
toujours souri en lisant même fait de la
langue ou leur a toujours souhaité
d'aller au bout et de remonter en vente
la division on a simplement constaté que
sur les trois dernières saisons ou
quatre a fait 80 qu'ils sont quatre
lequel dernière saison 3 secondes avant
at il manqué simplement de perspectives
et d'humilité pour pouvoir mettre les
bons ingrédients pour voir remonter qui
semble être la place qu'il mérite
cette défaite est peut-être un la
première défaite a été un déclic peut
être de se dire finalement vous pas
passer outre passer à travers une
nouvelle saison c'est ce que je sais ça
ruine une défaite bien et certaines
défaites
sauf en matrice en serrant la vis qui
esquisse qui a fait ce qui a fait le
petit déclencher le déclic qui qui les a
plus plus que je pense que nos propos ce
plateau rigaudiat ce que ben fallait
qu'ils revoient un petit peu leur copie
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait de belle
manière et là comme j'ai dit ils sont
dans une belle inspiration qui sont
coupés voodoo à donner à la mauricie à
l'éffigie de
c'est des aiguilles à tricoter qu il
arrive nous avons ici à les fusils
d'hélène sports stéphane blida quelque
chose j'aimerais dire je ne connais pas
et j'ai toujours eu confiance en vous
est-ce qu'il faudra la démarcation à ce
qu'il faudra quand même attendre les
playoffs quand même pour les juger
finalement hélène jusqu'au jour sur le
ring mais pour l'instant c'est donc on
verra
ils ne sont pas encore sûrs de monter
toute façon pour la plongée vote serré à
confirmer non mais c'est ça pour aucun
match on peut présumer du résultat
à coup sûr mais je pense qu'ils sont
partis c'est bon on espère une partie
non mais là ils sont partis ces normes
et les juges et c'est un grand mot aussi
on n'est pas là pour juger qui que ce
soit voilà mais bon après moi je dis
simplement qu'ils y sont pour moi ils
sont bien partis et c'est tout ce qu'on
leur souhaite qu'ils continuent sur leur
lancée ils ont dû se dire les quatre
vérités et puis voilà quoi entendu il a
lâché oh et jusqu'à maintenant on n'a
pas beaucoup entendu c'est pas forcément
celui qu'on interviewe le plus c'est
vrai il est leur équipe mais je pense
qu'il est beaucoup plus dans le thème et
c'est ici s'il y arrive c'est qu'ils se
mettent
il est réservé puisque c'est lui qui des
rues de là des fadas n'est plus réservé
la défense sur la défensive mais je
pense qu'il mériterait d'être si c'est
pas le cas être encore plus écoutés
parce que là il est dans le dos en tout
cas on invitera sur des prochaines
éditions
ils ont le 7-8 sport alors le prochain
match point est empli d un cours sera
donc le 1er mars prochain sur le terrain
des diables rouges de villepinte les
derniers du classement passe maintenant
notre page coup de projecteur
[Musique]
un mot de sport automobile à présent il
a tout juste 16 ans et n'a pas son
permis en poche mais il rêve de conduire
un jour une formule 1 mais avant cela
evans peine les qu'habite montigny le
bretonneux va participer cette année à
la porsche carrera cup france après
avoir passé une saison à f4 nous
l'avions reçu dans le 7-8 sport vous
voulez participer à la porsche carrera
cup
pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est
porsche porsche c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde
tout le monde connait c'est s'aider
voiture l'a donc j'étais en monoplace
l'année dernière là on passa de là
j'étais content d'être un univers
complètement différent là la voiture
n'est pas la même donc donc voilà ça
change complètement et c'est gorge c'est
une grosse famille et donc voilà très
content de pouvoir participer à ce
championnat
les mêmes vous voulez réagir ça fait
huit ans qu'ils pilotent je trouve ça
incroyable
il doit avoir une fille l'expérience
cette fois c'est leur saison
il a commencé qui on arrive et vous
allez voir hélène il était très petit
voilà pour les carburants
il était un peu plus grand il avait 15
ans et 15-16 ans donc c'était il ya un
an un an et demi alors en tout cas la
question sur ce thème fait-il le bon
choix en intégrant la porsche carrera
cup france plutôt que de vouloir
rejoindre tout de suite la formule 1 oui
ou non il a 16 ans il avait 16 ans le
partager j'en vois pas faire de duels
non mais moi je suis partagé pour la
seule bonne raison c'est que alors tenez
pas sur l'objectif mais je pense qu' il
est aussi il en parle de lucidité juste
avant avec le sujet justement lui aussi
fait pour avoir mon avis de lucidité
parce que vouloir être pilote de formule
1 c'est tout le c'est le rêve de tout le
monde dans toutes les disciplines on
veut on va
atteindre le maximum le plus haut mais
sauf qu'il est peut-être un petit peu
lucide et que des pilotes de formule 1
n'a pas erré pas des masses et que là le
fait de dalé / / / porsche
va peut-être lui ouvrir un petit peu
plus de portes et lui permettre de
pouvoir avoir une voiture et d'évoluer
et de conduire parce que le chemin est
très long pour arriver en formule 1 et
il y en a très peu qui arrive on le voit
bien ils sont très peu comme pilote
donc là je pense qui à son âge déjà il a
déjà plus fait preuve déjà d'une grande
lucidité une grande maturité en se
disant bon jeu de tête essayer d'aller
choper la formule 1 mais il ya là
tonnoir va se refermer très vite et
alors que la par rapport à mes
compétences et par rapport à déjà mon
ancienneté
ben je peux me permettre de taper à la
porte de ce championnat qui va
certainement plus m'offrir la
possibilité d'exercer mon rêve que aller
taper le plus haut possible
donc pour moi pour moi c'est pour ça
j'étais un petit peu mitigées quoi pour
information le ministère des sports a
récemment reconnu comme sportif de haut
niveau ce qui peut lui permet de devenir
du coup professionnels d'autant plus
voilà la nama pour l'ancien maître
d'avoir plus d'expérience
après on sait pas combien de temps il va
il va rester et verse rester chez
porsche peut-être qui fera qu'une qu'une
saison que c'est il restera plusieurs
années mais les jeunes gens une saison
soit 7 heures quand je te prennent déjà
ce qu'il ya à prendre l'expérience les
équipes
comment dire le la maison porsche a
forcément des choses à apprendre et puis
comme disait jean je pense que la
formule 1 me setc triés sur le volet il
ya très peu de personnes il va pouvoir
voir si c'est vraiment il va pouvoir
c'est celle à qui veut aller ou
peut-être sur d'autres d'autres courses
il saura voilà ça va lui quand même
mieux voir les portes donc ces femmes
je crois que les objectifs c'est de
faire un podium déjà et ensuite faire de
la f2 en 2022 et intégrer la f1 en 2023
donc déjà il a bon papa déjà il sait où
il veut aller
voilà en tout cas il à la formule 1 en
tête pour 2023
alors en 2019 il a déterminé sixième du
championnat de france f4 fia il est ami
deuxième en vie sur le circuit de pau
les gagner à magny cours
donc il ya il a quand même du potentiel
pierre chevallier
willy il a clairement du potentiel moi
je reprendrai simplement l'analogique
d'utiliser lui sur la famille la famille
de porsche qu'il intégrerait et ans
comparaît en comparaison avec les degrés
de maturité ou là pour l'instant c'est
un enfant c'est un fils un fils de
saison et la formule 1 la formule 2
d'ailleurs et la formule 1 sont sont
réservés aux papas et dans l'histoire du
sport automobile français
si on regarde un petit peu dans le rétro
il ya il ya finalement peu de pilotes
qui ont percé à 16 ans ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter cette nature est
tranquillement les panis les hérésies
les grosjean les gros jean charest et
hommes mais à 18 19 verges et à peine
également à commencé à 17 ans voilà donc
il est dont il est dans les rangs fait
il est dans le rythme il est vraiment
dans le rythme il stefan le rap
élimination des as sont planqués tout
tracé intégrer une écurie comme une
écurie comme la famille porsche c'est
une formation sur des sur des moteurs et
des voitures qui sont juste dingue il ya
de quoi se faire les dents et se faire
le ce faire le ces armes là dessus après
derrière qu'on lui laisse le qu'on lui
laisse le temps on en parle suffisamment
souvent dans tous les sports
j'en pensais peut-être tout à l'heure à
la boxe aussi affirme il ya peu d'élus
il faut que ça il faut que ça mature
pour arriver où top au top mondial à à
vouloir aller trop vite
puisqu'on parle de sport automobile et
de formule 1 il peut peut-être aller
dans le mur donc c'est évidemment ce
n'est pas ce qu'on lui souhaite
et je pense que c'est un bon choix
d'avoir il n'a inter étape
et pour revenir ce que vous disiez les
pilotes aussi commencent de plus en plus
tôt
finalement est-ce que c'est pas se
griller finalement pour la formule 1
d'opter je crois en des sciences de la
conel leurs applis peu il peut avoir
simplement une saison une saison ou deux
intégrés à 17 ans révolus ou à 18 ans ça
me semble pas 200 kilomètres heure
bien au contraire bien au contraire je
rappelle le calendrier de cette porsche
carrera cup le 5 avril ce sera le départ
à barcelone ils ont ensuite à spa aux 24
heures du mans à monza à magny cours et
sur le circuit paul ricard
ça va il ya pire janvier et a pas son
permis il n'a pas son permis encore
hélas pas son permis de conduire
le rendez vous le plus important ça sera
les 24 heures du mans il va courir
devant 350 mille personnes juste avant
le départ ça c'est une belle expérience
et ça voilà c'est une expérience à son
âge unique
ça vous choque
passé par des courses comme celle là ça
lui permet de piloter
il ya je pense que sur des championnats
comme ça sur des courses comme ça il ya
plus de il ya plus de courses
donc c'est lui il aime piloter il peut
voilà il peut le faire en formule 1
voilà il n'y a pas beaucoup de courses
possible donc on attend toujours la
course rassemble intégré à l'iphone
alors pour pour les puristes il va
conduire sur une gt3 un moteur six
cylindres avec une puissance de 485
chevaux pour pour les puristes ans je
sais que vous avez un est un genre tu
tenais à préciser c'est très physique et
valentin qu'il faut qu'il ait le
physique pour encaisser la poussée il
fait 2 à 3 fois du sport par semaine
il ya encore peut-être un petit peu
croissante qu'il faut le ménager encore
ménagé alors on lui souhaite en tout cas
une belle carrière on continuera le sud
sur tv soixante dix huit ans continue
cette page coup de projecteur part du
cyclisme la sélection piste pour les
championnats du monde de berlin a été
dévoilé il ya quelques jours ce rendez
vous est organisé à partir d'aujourd'hui
ce mercredi 26 février et durera jusqu'à
ce dimanche 1er mars font office de test
à quelques mois des jeux olympiques
l'une des stars de cette équipe de
france saura quentin lafargue les vinoy
licencié au vc le sky avait remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre et l'argent en
vitesse par équipes sur les derniers
mondiaux en 2019 réaction c'est toujours
un moment important cette sélection est
et ce championnat du monde tous les ans
qui revient mais qui fait toujours
plaisir à enfin de porter porté les
couleurs des équipes de france
au plus haut niveau donc je l'attendais
je l'espérais et je suis content de
faire partie du collectif
alors je rappelle que quentin afin qu'à
29 ans il perce vraiment depuis deux ans
au plus haut niveau
la question sur ce thème doit-on tout
misé sur lui surtout sur cette année
olympique
oui ou non on est pas les spécialistes
sikhisme a rejeté a précisé
salo trouvez vous suivez quand même
régulièrement les cours ils voulaient le
rebond on écoute y adopter un petit dieu
j'en ai s'embêter avec la question de
droite ou doit-on tout misé en fait
c'est un travail d'équipé ya plusieurs
disciplines donc
donc oui oui mais parce que bien sûr on
me sur ses performances et on veut que
veulent ou non mais on veut qu'il se
réalise on sait très bien pourquoi il a
il a intégré l'équipe et on compte bien
fortement sur lui pour les disciplines
dans lesquelles il va concourir mais
après voilà c'est il n'est pas seul à
courir il yad'autres d'autres pistard
avec lui d'autres disciplines aussi
qu'ils sont pas forcément sa discipline
à lui donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas que
lui mais dans ce pourquoi il est bon oui
mais tout
tout nous est suspendu moi j'ai mines
ont tout misé sur lui pourquoi parce
qu'il avait neuf ans donc c'est pas il
ya quand même une génération de jeunes
au niveau international qui poussent et
qui est talentueuse donc entre deux
générations en fait finalement la
confiance est là grégory baugé mickaël
d'almeida qui vont vers leurs 35 34 ans
24 voilà 24 ans mais bon 22,9 il est
calme et 2 voilà les nouvelles élites ce
fichier est un qu'il en 21 ans voilà 20
ans 21 ans donc là ils sont il est
effectivement entre les deux alors entre
les deux on va dire que des côtes et
îles et qu'un plus près de la sortie que
degrés
mais on va miser tout sur lui parce que
elle elle l'a dit c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi elle a dit oui mais s'est quant
à elle a fait exprès mais mais c'est
vrai que c'est une équipe quand c'est
une équipe ce n'est pas individuel c'est
une équipe et encore une fois il ya qu'à
29 ans il est je pense qu'on peut
l'utiliser on peut l'utiliser parce
qu'il est en pleine forme actuellement
ce chapelet aliments deviennent
deviennent bien avant préparation des jo
je crois qu'il va faire pour moi il va
faire quelque chose il va réaliser
quelque chose à ce championnat du monde
mais on peut passer pas c'est pour moi
c'est pas le fer de lance de l'équipe de
france du cyclisme
il ya cette génération de jeunes qui
arrivent derrière et qu'on l'a dit a
déjà parlé ici sur son talent sur ce
plateau qui fait un bon mixte avec les
pseudos anciens lui est entre les deux
il fait un petit peu l'unité entre les
anciens et les jeunes
donc c'est vraiment un travail d'équipé
et je crois qu'il a il a largement sa
place
on peut compter sur lui donc pour vous
il faudrait enlever les idéaux et baugé
et michael d'almeida pour les enlever
parce qu'on en a parlé ici pour moi
c'est l'expérience qui a été mis en
relation avec la jeunesse
il faut de tout il faut il faut pas que
que de la fouille de la jeunesse il faut
de l'expérience là on a montré
ils ont montré que ça marchait ils ont
montré que ça fonctionnait exigeant
qu'il ya eu des résultats
lui il est juste entre les deux vous
l'avez dit vous-même il est entre les
deux lui c'est ce qui c'est ce genre de
deux cyclistes qui fait la jonction
entre la jeune génération et la
génération d'expériences que sont
gregory baugé et sa conformément à ce
que tout misé sur les qui lisait sur lui
ça voudrait dire qu'on
qu'on ne considère que les disciplines
dans lequel lui sa ligne comme le disait
il n ya toutes les lignes à toutes les
équipes il ya toutes les disciplines
petit décision que je voulais apporter
quentin lafargue est un crack sur le
kilomètre principalement une épreuve où
on est seul en piste et on doit réaliser
quatre tours le plus rapidement possible
il a remporté le bronze au championnat
du monde en 2016 l'argent en 2017 et
surtout l'or l'an dernier mais il n'y a
pas d'épreuve tu km aux jeux olympiques
il allait coincer ces fiches à toutes
les disciplines par équipes
et puis c'est aussi dire que si on mise
tout sur quentin lafargue quid des défis
aussi parce qu'on dieu sait qu'on a des
on a des pépites aussi dans les yvelines
sur les vélos chez chez les dames et
donc donc non on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas tout miser sur lui
en revanche il ay là il va avoir un
impact il va avoir une influence sur
l'équipe de france parce qu'il est il
est sûrement pleine bourre en ce moment
il est revanchard par rapport à une
nouvelle ligne mans à rio donc il va
arriver à tokyo et les bébés et les
bêtes aligné à arriver au dernier moment
il a raté les jo de défauts sacha danino
et ce chaînon manquant entre les
générations donc on peut pas tout miser
sur lui sportivement mais peut-être
peut-être humainement il a quand même
gagné quand même sept médailles lors des
championnats du monde notamment
c'était une jambe on va prendre assez
bon donc pour vous on continue avec
quentin voilà il faut y aller c'est
parti ça roule ça va aller alors on
reviendra plus largement sur ces
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste et les performances des français
notamment de quentin lafargue dans un
prochain
si on parlait sport
[Musique]
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
football la rencontre entre maurepas et
montigny le bretonneux de coupe d
immunité arbitré par une femme cécile à
bessières est une habituée des matchs de
district a fait partie des quatre
arbitres féminines dans le département
chiffres faibles qui devrait augmenter
dans les prochains mois jean-pierre
mérillon le pré responsable du district
a mis en place des actions auprès des
clubs en écoute jean pierre burillon
c'était il ya neuf mois le nombre
minimum d'arbitré vous avez des
sanctions pour calculer le nombre
d'arbitrés fournis par les clubs concept
une arbitres féminines
elle compte pour 2 alors là aussi on m'a
dit 'ce tout discret c'est de la
discrimination oui mais elle est
positive j'assume
voilà c'est pour inciter les klaba nous
amener des arbitres féminines 2 arbitres
sont actuellement en cours de formation
total il n'y a que quatre arbitres
féminines sur 300 arbitres dans tout le
district la question est simple comment
expliquer un si faible taux de femmes
arbitres dans le football je dis oui ou
pas par pièce et on a plus besoin
demandez votre avis c'est sûr mais c'est
sûrement vrai sur tous corps confondus
c'est pas et sait pas c'est pas vrai que
je pense que c'est pas vrai qu'au
football parce que si on prend les le
le cas du rugby j'ai je n'ai vu sur les
dix dernières années qu'un seul match
cette saison
arbitrée par une fille en fédérale 3
femmes en fédérale 3 et c'est sûrement
dû alors dans le football dans le rugby
ou dans d'autres sports qui sont plutôt
plutôt masculin au départ qu'il ya peu
au départ un jouet j'insiste bien sur le
départ puisque il ya de la pratique
féminine dans ces sports là qu'on est
moins de vocations qu'on est moins de
vocations chez les dames d'abord sur la
pratique du sport autant thème du
football du faux bond dans les équipes
féminines et du rugby dans les équipes
féminines et qu'au football
il y ait peu de peu deux dames qui
décide finalement de laisser de laisser
les crampons sportif pour aller prendre
le sifflet donc c'est simplement aussi
vraisemblablement une question de point
de vue et une question de une question
d'ouverture d'esprit je dis disons le
tout de go
parce que on a ce soit ça fait ça fait
ricaner soit ça soit on al'impression
pouvoir prendre prendre de l'influent
sur sur une arbitre une arbitres
féminines
d'ailleurs comme dans beaucoup de mots
de la langue française il n'y a pas
forcément féminin pour arbitres
donc voilà le cqfd mais si on voit les
uniquement les images et pas assisté au
match monte à montigny mais uniquement
les images il semble y avoir un respect
à un respect total de cet arbitre n ya
pas eu départ donc et donc est donc une
respect de la discipline et d'un respect
de l'autorité
donc la preuve si bien que rien que les
dames sont aussi des bons des bons
arbitres il ya aussi il ya aussi un
point de sémantique dans la langue
française qui devrait aussi inventer des
mots féminins pour ces mots qui sont a
priori misogyne au départ jean vous
rejoignez la pierre sur l'arbitrage oui
notamment le rugby un cessez votre celi
du cco costa tout à fait hélas très peu
aussi en ile de france
très peu
très peu leurs beats au féminin l'équipe
mais comment se doit mais au niveau de
l'arbitrage je fasse que c'est une
frappe le disque est bien parce que la
construction
la vocation du sepa ne sais pas
évidemment déjà je pense que c'est pas
évident mais déjà si on regarde au
niveau international ternational
exemplarité on l'a vu à l'image
stéphanie fera part qui est la première
française à avoir arbitré un match
professionnel a également arbitré la
supercoupe d'europe en 2010 neuf et ça
s'est très bien passé les moins de
contestations effectivement pierre
chevallier
voilà voilà c'est extrêmement c'est
extrêmement rare raison finalement au
niveau international donc il ya comme
dans beaucoup de disciplines sportives
et d'une manière générale dans le sport
il ya un déficit d'exemple d'exemple et
donc de vocations qui donne qui donne
l'envié à d'autres
d'autres femmes de prendre le sifflet
quel que soit justement à ces milliers
sur les sciences et si c'est une
publicité c'est un génie fera part si on
regarde bien pour les autres filles oui
alors c'est une publicité mais voilà
ouais c'est une publicité le savez ça me
plaît pas vraiment une publicité parce
que c'est bien si c'est un exemple voilà
c'est un exemple de réussite je préfère
le mot exemple que plus visités
mais si le mois là je suis pas d'accord
c'est que on dit voilà c'est une femme
qui arbitre donc ça se passe mieux
je mange pas dans le monde du football
je parle bien le monde du football ça se
passe mieux parce que c'est une femme
qui arbitra là là je ne suis pas
d'accord je me lève contre ça parce que
j'estime et on le voit tous les
week-ends tous les bacs de football
aujourd'hui c'est le règlement qu'il
faudrait qu'ils changent là je vais
encore citer le rubicon maintien mais un
arbitre au rugby on se permet pas de lui
dire
dire le moindre petit mot c'est carton
rouge directement voilà au football
homme ou femme ce n'est pas y'a pas de
2,2 distinction larbitre dans toute sa
splendeur
on ne le respecte un arbitre au rugby
vous lui dites tech arlon ses dehors
c'est carton rouge en voilà au football
lorsque moi je vois je regarde les
matches de ligue 1 où je vois les
joueurs qui sont à sa de l'armee
transhumants qui s'organise voilà c'est
une équipe qui songerait à allah lui à
lui sauter dessus mais non leur chef
gilles charger votre règlement fait
respecter votre corps arbitral il y aura
pas besoin de dire c'est une femme et ça
se passe mieux à les respecter vaches et
non là je suis pas d'accord parce que
justement sur veut l'égalité qui est
recherchée qui est demandé mais on
n'avance pas ce genre de 2,2 de propos
est de 2,2 chose à l'avant côté
subjectif à l'arbitrage que quel que
soit le sport et que ce soit pour les
hommes et pour les femmes et qui
n'attend pas de savoir quel est le sexe
de larbitre pour pour déterminer si si
s'il est performant ou pas performantes
ou pas c'est à la fin du match qu'on
regarde qu'on regarde en fait la
performance est là sur l'autre chose que
je peux en juger avec eux avec une une
arbitre féminine
c'est simplement une différence de
présentation des choses après façon
d'être sûrement qui en impose
différemment par contre elle n'est pas
forcément plus respectés parce que c'est
une femme c'est la manière la manière de
tenir le match qui va qui va qui va
insuffler vermine et le respect et la
discipline et c'est vrai que s'il faut
comparer les deux sports il ya un
respect naturel au rugby que l'on ne
retrouve pas au football c'est vrai que
là l'exemplarité des pros en la matière
j'ai été j'ai été signé parce que j'ai
vu sur le psg bordeaux de dimanche
dernier avec avec des débordements sur
le terrain des joueurs eux-mêmes et en
dehors du terrain par leurs familles qui
se permettent d'intervenir sur sur un
niveau d'arbitrage on nage en plein
délire et au niveau local est ce que ça
fonctionne l'arbitrage féminin hélène au
niveau local au local c'est-à-dire le
public les joueurs je pense que c'est un
peu surprenant parce qu'on n'en voit pas
mais
ça peut donner aussi envie de peut-être
plus suivre le match pour voir
c'est un regard différent avoir
peut-être sur le match oui je pense que
c'est ça intéressant est ce qu a pas
trop de pression justement des fois
aussi au niveau local
est-ce que l'ex de stéphanie fera part
mais qui finalement est protégé par la
fifa par les instances françaises
c'est un côté un côté autorité naturelle
et façon de présenter différentes façons
d'être différente mais ça me faisait
penser justement à ce match là qui avait
été arbitré par une somme âge de rugby
qui avait arbitré par une femme est là
et on assiste à des scènes assez
cocasses avec des supporters qui doivent
revoir complètement complètement leur
vocabulaire et leurs vannes le refrain
habituel on est toujours bon enfant sur
un oeil à réduire dans les tribunes de
rugby et les vannes qui fut généralement
sur les arbitres mais l'amérique latine
sont les réinventer il faut les
réinventer pour les dames
parce que justement ça ne fait suite à
des quarante années de d'arbitrage
masculin et plus et là il faut revoir un
petit peu le vocabulaire c'est assez
rigolo
c'était fin de l'ingérence que le rugby
depuis le rugby le foot depuis la nuit
des temps c'est ces deux cultures
différentes
on n'a jamais vu un rib humaine défoncer
la tête d'un arbitre
c'est quelque chose on verra jamais
savouré demi au niveau international en
aucun cas au foot on voit des choses
le rapport mais le fait qu'ils aient une
femme qui arbitre ça amène sa les freine
un peu j'ai l'impression que ça les
frênes impossible c'est presque tous
n'ont droit qu'au football ça se passe à
ce point bien comme sur le match je mens
pas me dit c'est c'est parce que
justement il n'y a pas cette culture du
respect du corps arbitral comme disent
les gens et malgré tout on fait 2 fait
ça se passe bien ça se passe
naturellement bien après après ce match
où il ya 4 0 oui il ya aussi un match
accroché tard est ici un match accroché
les tensions sont pas les mêmes parce
qu'il ya 2-0 à la mi-temps mm en 2 0 la
mi-temps et 4 0 à la fin du match 2 040
c'est ça donc c'est un match qui est pas
accroché sur le terrain
doc et on va dire entre guillemets
facile à arbitrer au vu du résultat j'ai
pas vu le match mais au vu du résultat
et de l'évolution du score c'était un
match facile à arbitrer maintenant sur
un match qui est c'est un petit peu plus
serré s'il y avait eu 2 2 peut-être que
je sais pas pareil au niveau de la
couche ce qui mettrait une arbitre
féminine sur une finale demie ou une
finale même d'écouter divine on verra
sur les prochains tours peut-être c'est
ce qu'on peut souhaiter
est ce que le travail est quand même
encore longue stephen ils arrivent petit
à petit l'ascendant très faible 1 4-6
potentiellement sur 3 4 sur 306
potentiellement dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines dit à petit va y en
avoir de plus en plus je pense parce que
l'on peut parler fort ce jour fait ces
gars là qu'il faudrait interroger en dix
ans qu'est ce qui vous a motivé
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qui vous
motive à arbitrer des matches des
matches de football masculin et
j'imagine des matches de football
féminin mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut qu est
ce qui vous a poussé à passer le pas et
à devenir et je pense que le fait qu'un
arbitre féminin en ligue 1 ça peut les
motiver à dire tiens pourquoi pas moi
après tout la médiatisation
voilà on va passer maintenant notre page
découverte
[Musique]
notre dernière thématique je vous
propose de découvrir un sport insolite a
testé la savate forme c'est une
discipline née et développé en france
qui allie ludique et technique pour la
fédération française de savate les
pratiquants de cette discipline
représentent environ 7% de leurs
licenciés on écoute l'un des professeurs
qui exerce la savate forme à maurepas
est-ce que la cravate forme alors la
savate forme c'est une discipline de la
fédération de boxe française de savate
boxe française et donc l'idée c'est de
mettre les techniques de savate boxe
française en musique ailleurs mode
fitness avec la possibilité aussi
lorsqu'on soit d'ajouter aussi locaux
discipline au sein de faire un cercle de
savate défense n'est donc l'idée c'est
de finesse des faits les cardiologues
fatigué en musique et en forme et en
chorégraphies et dans un autre esprit
pratique et les mouvements de la bourse
moi je suis fier guerrier vous avez
travaillé votre chorégraphié pendant le
ca me pour l'instant ça peut donner
l'impression que les gants sont plus
sont plus décorative voilà que c'est
parce que c'est la savate c'est de la
savatte services non non non pourquoi
dgo donc c'est décoratif
ces voix là comme s'il faisait de la
boxe c'est dans l'âme ouvert en faisant
du car des sports forme et bien-être
avec ce souk que ce soit comme avec la
savate comme point de départ la boxe ont
demandé par donc oui avec les rires avec
les grands décoratifs de toute façon ce
qui ce qui vous met en forme vous fait
du bien donc je pense que c'est une
c'est une bonne discipline a testé
justement j'avais vous demandez est ce
que cette unicité attesté oui ou non
voter mais pas de débat aujourd'hui
la curiosité la visite et surtout voir
voilà voir les échauffements comment ça
se passe les le contenu du cours
et puis l'évolution aussi du sport mais
après est ce que c'est je pas est ce que
c'est un peu comme la zone d'âge sais
pas trop c'est un jour c'est un peu un
mélange de son bail de boxe avoir un peu
l'évolution s'il ya vraiment beaucoup de
mouvements différence et c'est très
varié mes adjoints ils sont là qui a
testé était fatigué à la fin de la
fusion à haut niveau et pisa blessure
mais c'est le cardio ça voilà cessé
d'exercer grandir contre bon les gars
les gants voilà malheureusement que le
même sport n'existe pas par exemple avec
avec la plongée sous-marine dévoiler
leurs congés voilà un projet est
replongé avec le masque tuba les
bouteilles vides et silencieuses ici
aline éventuellement ancien nom mais
bien un créneau à prendre voit là bas
après si l'association chose de grand
public
- par rapport par rapport aux
disciplines qu'on découvre très souvent
et ça nous vous remercions de nous faire
découvrir autant de disciplines des
sciences sociales telles son plateau il
y a une dimension physique
là on peut dire soit dément six garçons
comme disaient les hou hou hou à
l'aquagym à l'aquagym sur la flotte
wallon bodycombat exactement il
manquerait uniquement peut-être la
dimension mentale mais à part ça ça
semble être la country savate et enfants
alors laisse maître par deux quand on
vous dit
comme si six touchés comme six touchés
en quelques sortes voilà je suis touché
et je me devais passer le cardio les
cours commencent et structurée à la joie
l'aide non mais vraiment trop fort et
sur les mutuelles les choses à 2 820
avant deux ans suit derrière
je m'étais par deux voilà il ya près d
étirements la fin bien sûr après il est
certain que il est certain que les gains
les gants les gars au niveau du travail
en eau
le fait d'avoir même si tu même si on
porte pas les coups le fait de faire des
mouvements avec les gants de boxe ça
fatigue c'est ça c'est vrai et
l'objectif final de ce sport c'est
d'attirer c'est ce public et pas
forcément voué à faire de la boxe ou de
la savatte vers ce sport là est ce que
stéphane ça peut se peut les attirer
pour faire vraiment de la boxe un peu
plus tard nos la banque non je pense pas
non c'est vrai que furie wilders est ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya tant de gens
aujourd'hui ya quand même de quoi que je
précise je lisais ya quand même beaucoup
de femmes donc après est ce que coûte un
jeu s'adresse vraiment à tout le monde
ou est ce que ça a été décliné un peu tu
as eu la sienne bercer d'illusions je
peux vous affirmer l'année je pense que
ça
46 mettait des coupes même la banque je
pense
pendant ce temps c'est encourir à la
capoeira
c'est la capoeira danse avec des coûts
savard quidditch
je suis obligé de vous arrêter c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission est amenée
comme d'habitude par une citation au
jour d'aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de l'ancien footballeur eric
cantona quand les mouettes suivent un
chalutier c'est qu'elles pensent qu'on
va leur jeter des sardines
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78,6
[Musique]